hi George Lucy from Sky News and you
said you'll Ryder on this tour would be
quite boring and what kind of lifestyle
choices and changes have you made to
enable you to go on tour and to do this
album because you're looking great well
thank you well let me see well I'll be
obvious one is is well actually now I'm
not going to go into this I'm not going
to go into this because it will be
tomorrow in the newspaper so it's
another tweet question I'm sorry I've
got to keep it to the music you know me
I like to talk about myself but um but
it's normally funnier on Twitter anyway
it's really a matter of thinking what
can I do to contribute as a gay man
because I have serious problem with the
fact that every time I make a big
mistake every time I would I would let
myself down I felt definitely that I was
letting young gay kids down because they
would then witness the homophobia that
was thrown at me in the wording of that
homophobia the language that's legal in
this country so I have I have I feel I
have I like to think that life is a
balance and whenever there's something
bad there's something good you can do
with it so I have some plans to try and
do things to help get children and I
think we're notoriously bad as a
community at helping our own when it
comes to children because we don't have
our own children